vous connaissez
le comté qui me pose prochaine question
Bixente
album plus commercial
alors par commercial je suppose que tu
entends un album moins spirituel parce
que tous mes albums sont vendus dans les
magasins donc sans commercialisés
commerciales comme commercial je ne sais
pas je ne sais pas parce que je le fais
à chaque fois
sa tête pour passer c'est très bien je
fais de mon mieux je sais pas quoi vous
dire
[Musique]
si je te dis je me verse 7000 par mois
je sais même pas honnêtement combien je
me verserai je sais très bien que c'est
plus que correct qu'on a la chance de
pas pour pas regarder le prix nos
courses etc et rien que ça tu vois c'est
ouf dans la période actuelle ou même
l'essence tu vois de pas comparer les
prix des sens c'est une chance mais en
même temps c'est pas une chance parce
que on suffit quand même niveau taf tu
vois donc j'ai pas j'ai aucun problème à
parler d'argent mais en chiffre
d'affaires tu sais combien vous faites à
peu près à l'année je sais pas si on
fait 2 millions tu donnes quand même un
petit million à l'état français chaque
année
[Musique]
salut c'est Jeff et ça c'est moi au
début de la soirée c'est déjà et là
c'est la fin de la soirée
absolument à rien bu pour le moment
rendez-vous tout de suite au je
m'appelle Nico et tout va bien tout va
très bien je ramène qui je ramène qui je
dépose qui
bonjour je suis Cauet je suis en début
de soirée bon je serai identique à la
fin de la soirée évidemment bonsoir
c'est la fin de la soirée mais je
préfère rester masqué pour qu'on me
reconnaisse pas